last time I told you that Sumerian had a
massive influence on later to name upon
languages I spared you the details
though until now here's my favorite
example of Sumerian ization run amok
Sumerian cuneiform built words with two
kinds of characters syllable characters
and these kind of picture word
characters so scribes could write about
a star by drawing the word character
star or spelling it with the syllables
mu and mu Sumerian for star when the
Akkadians took over cuneiform they
grabbed that word symbol and also
syllables to write Kabu their own
Akkadian word for star but the Acadians
kept around some Sumerian baggage
actually a lot of Sumerian baggage which
led them to a bizarre third option spell
the word in Sumerian but pronounce it in
Akkadian this technique let them
transform Sumerian words into new
symbols Samara Graham's Akkadian words
with Sumerian Spelling's the Hittites
got sucked into this when they joined
the Akkadian cuneiform party the native
Hittite word for backwards was Appa
reasonably Hittites scribes wrote it
with three characters but they could
also switch in the Sumerian word for
back and write it this way with the
Sumaira gram it wasn't just Samara grams
though the Hittites turned this around
on the Acadians creating akkada grams
here's a strange example Akkadian used
lots of little prepositions kind of like
English unamed for as in Anna Lou gaw
for the King no surprise king is in
Sumerian there Hittite work differently
it had all of these indo-european case
endings
therefore the King had a root pursue and
an attached ending II dative case or for
like in Latin or Greek oddly Hittites
scribes could write the Akkadian
preposition Anna next to the Sumerian
lugal even while they read it as the
Hittite noun with the case ending what a
mess just imagine if English writers
glorify the language this much it's like
writing the word city in Greek but
insisting that those characters spell
the Sound City and then in a phrase like
or the city will slap a Latin case
ending on to the Greek gram here see
this means money for the city obviously
actually Sumeria kata grams are worse at
least Greek Latin and English are
related Hittite Akkadian and Sumerian
are three different beasts anyhow that's
one very quirky example of the kind of
linguistic influence Sumerian cuneiform
had on later civilizations stick around
throughout 2015 for more about writing
and subscribe for language
you